Claw enables rich VR interactions in a
compact, handheld free-moving device.
With claw you can grasp ritual objects and
feel appropriate forces during grasping.
You can also touch and feel the shape of
a virtual object as well as get
resistance when you push on them.
You can also rub virtual surfaces and
feel their texture rendered underneath
your fingertip. Finally, you can also feel
the recoil when shooting the virtual
weapon. Claw is a unique, multi-functional
haptic controller that enables grasping,
touching,
surface texture rendering,
and shooting feedback.
By reading the thumb position using a
proximity sensor
our controller changes its haptic mode
between grasping and touching
We use a force center located at the
fingertip mount to enable closed loop
force feedback control system with a
servo motor.
The servo motor only reacts
to the forces exerted by the index finger.
With the closed loop force control
we can render variable stiffness.
For example, users can grab and feel
solid virtual objects but also soft
deformable virtual objects.
A voice coil actuator at the fingertip generates
different patterns of vibration which
are used for texture rendering.
Coupled with the 3D hand tracking data
the voice coil actuator vibrates only
when the user moves their hand. When
shooting, the servo motor moves back and
forth quickly to simulate recoil
sensation.
In summary, the clock controller integrates multiple haptic technologies into a VR controller device
capable of rendering compelling force
feedback while grasping, touching,
and shooting in virtual reality.